- Don't you dare, Jimmy, what is-
(class laughing)
- Oh yeah?
Oh yeah?
(trilling tongue)
Well, this is you, Jimmy.
(screaming and whooping)
(beatboxing and bass music)
(audience murmuring)
- Mr. Cook, you're almost up.
Are you ready?
- Good, I'm good.
- Okay, really gonna need
you to stick to the script
on this one.
- I'm the CEO of Apple, Willis.
I'm not gonna do anything stupid.
Please stop comparing me to Steve Jobs.
- No, nobody's comparing
you to Steve Jobs.
Okay, just want you to
focus on the products
and please stick to the script.
Okay, you're on in three.
- They're gonna forget they
ever heard the name Steve Jobs.
What up Apple people?
(audience applauding)
Yeah.
Yeah!
Well, the first thing that I'm gonna do is
TOTS: Throw Out The Script.
Now, I'm supposed to come out here
and tell you about some bull (beep)
new iPhone pad, pod dick, ***** (beep).
You've seen it.
(mockingly stuttering)
Boring.
(audience applauding)
- Yes, that's exactly it.
Now, let's say that
this table, right here,
let's say it's Bill Gates, huh?
(growling)
(crashing)
(audience applauding)
- Yeah, what's up, what's up, what's up?
Ha, ha, ha, that's what I'm talking about.
And let's say that this is our
competitor's new smartphone.
(audience booing)
How about that?
Huh? What? Ugh!
(glass smashing)
(audience applauding)
I am Android.
I am a major donkey dick.
Woo!
(audience applauding)
Right?
And let's say that this, right here,
this is one of our
competitor's new ebook readers.
Huh? What about that?
(crowd booing)
What? Uh oh.
Tut, tut.
Wooks wike wain.
Ha.
(audience applauding)
- [Audience Member] Yeah, yeah!
- Woo!
Woo!
Yeah!
All right! Yes.
Who wants to see some of that
classified next level (beep), huh?
(audience applauding)
Did Steve ever show you
that classified (beep)?
No, he didn't.
(audience applauding)
- You can't do that, they
haven't been tested yet.
- This device will allow you to teleport
anywhere on the planet.
Check this out.
I am the future.
(zapping)
(screaming)
(sizzling)
- Woo!
Let's see Steve Jobs do that.
Ha, ha, ha!
(metal clanking)
(intense music)
- Okay, man, you know what?
It, it wasn't my fault, alright?
I, I, I, I had the money,
like you said in a trash bag
in the back of my car
and I was going to go
straight to the drop spot, all right?
(intense music continues)
No, no, oh, okay.
Okay, okay, no, no,
hey, hey, hey, hey, man.
There ain't no need for you
to get comfortable, okay?
Because, because I, I'm telling you, man,
what happened wasn't my fault, all right?
I, I, I, I, I, I, I drove to
the agreed upon location, man.
Oh, come on man.
Come on.
Okay, okay. Okay.
Okay. Becau- Becau-, okay,
because there's no need
to have anything crazy
in a paper bag.
I'm telling you, there's an
explanation for what went down.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, let's calm down now.
Let's calm down, man.
There ain't no need.
Oh, not a juice box.
There ain't no need to eat a meal.
And then do some crazy (beep)
with a sandwich container
and a juice box.
Oh, man, come on.
Come on, man.
Just chill out a little bit.
Just, you need to relax, man.
You need to take it easy and relax.
Oh (beep).
Oh *******.
Look, come on, man.
Don't do it, don't do it.
Don't, don't, man, you-
Come on, man, oh, eating the sandwich.
He eating the sandwich now.
(sobbing)
Man, how you gon' sandwich me, dog?
How you gon' sandwich me?
Oh (beep), okay, look,
it's getting crazy now.
It's gotta stop.
It's gotta stop right now, okay?
You cleaning yourself up
before you do some ill (beep).
Come on, man.
What you doing?
What you wanna know?
What? I'll tell you whatever
you want to know, man.
Just please stop this
cold *** (beep), man.
I'm begging you dog, please.
Oh (beep) no, no.
Okay. Look, okay, man.
Maybe it was my fault a little bit.
Maybe it's my fault a little bit.
But don't just, what you gonna
do with that juice box, man?
What gonna do with that?
What you gonna do with straw?
What you gonna do with a straw?
Come on, man.
Listen, listen.
No, no, no, I did it.
I did it, I did it, okay?
I did it, I did it.
I left the car.
I left for three minutes.
So please don't do
anything with the straw.
Why don't you aren't you stop-
(intensifying music)
No, fine, fine.
Ah! Oh! Ah!
There, okay, man.
Ha ha, beat you to it.
Okay? I got your point, all right, man.
Ah!
Oh man, that's a *****.
(screaming)
(car whirring)
- Will we be having any more
problems out of him, sir?
- No.
- Yeah, that's what I'm talking about.
- [Bill] We're coming to
the end of the first quarter
with the Rhinos in the red
zone for the first time.
- [Jeff] Gotta say Bill, I
like watching these rhinos.
- [Bill] Ransom takes the snap,
drops back with good protection.
And that's a completed pass
(crowd cheers)
to a very wide open Hingle McCringleberry,
the rookie out of Penn State.
- [Jeff] Nice grab by McCringleberry,
you think he's happy?
- [Bill] Oh boy, he is
loving it down there.
- [Jeff] Oh, we got something
of a shooting gallery going on.
- [Bill] Oh yeah, look at that.
Boy, that is something.
(whistling)
And oh, whoa, wait, we got a flag there.
- Well, he got called for-
- Is that for
excessive celebration?
- No.
- [Bill] Oh, see and I'm
not sure about that call.
- [Jeff] I don't know, bill.
That was three pumps in the rule book
says you cannot have more than two.
- [Bill] Oh my gosh, but look at the kid.
He's pleading his case
- Yeah, but...
- [Bill] with the ref.
Pleading his case.
- [Jeff] Yeah, clearly three pumps.
- [Bill] Coach Johnson,
definitely not happy about this call.
Five minutes into the
fourth quarter, 3rd and 10,
the Rhinos, again, threatening to score.
Can the Cougars hold them?
- [Jeff] Big play coming here, Bill.
- [Bill] Ransom takes
the snap, drops back.
He floats one into the end zone.
And McCringleberry pulls it down.
(whistling)
- [Jeff] He's got it.
- [Bill] Oh my gosh.
For his second touchdown
of the day for this rookie,
he has gotta be feeling
great about himself.
- Nicely done.
- Love the confidence.
- [Jeff] I'll tell you, man, he's oh-
- Oh, oh, see, now there's two pumps.
- [Jeff] Yeah, he's really
testing the boundaries
and he's clearly gotten
the ref's attention here.
- [Bill] A third pump will
draw a flag no matter what.
(whistling)
See? Oh, he just did it again.
(Jeff groans)
- [Bill] What is, now what is that?
The second time?
Now you have to flag him on it.
- [Jeff] Yeah, you had to, you know, Bill,
it's just frustrating seeing young players
without the ability to
restrain themselves.
- [Bill] Oh, it really is.
It, it's hard.
- [Jeff] I mean, the ref's
gonna get you every time.
- [Bill] Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
Ah, see now the ref agrees.
That's three pumps right there.
(whooshing)
And the quarterback, Ransom, under center.
Last five minutes of the game,
Rhinos are marching here again.
- [Jeff] Hard to stop this
team from scoring, Bill.
They have so many weapons.
- [Bill] Ransom takes the snap
and it's a shovel pass
to McCringleberry who-
(crowd roaring)
He's at the 10.
He's at the five and touchdown Rhinos.
- [Jeff] Oh, my great
block by Hardunkachud.
And that's gonna be tough for
the Cougars to come back from.
- Boy, what a career day
from Hingle McCringleberry,
the rookie out of Penn state.
Oh, he is just amazingly
fired up here today, Jeff.
- [Jeff] You gotta love
the way this guy plays
and he, oh...
- Oh.
See now there's one pump.
Oh
- Uh, oh.
- [Bill] Well, I cannot believe this kid.
- [Jeff] You gotta put your team first
in situations like this
and McCringleberry's just not doing that.
- [Bill] Oh, now there's two, Jeff,
now if he pumps a third time he will
draw his third penalty for today.
Everybody here waiting with bated breath.
(whistling)
- He did it.
- Oh, did he?
- [Jeff] Yes, he did it.
- Oh, that's just amazing.
- He couldn't help himself.
I mean, come on in professional
football it's really-
- [Jeff] It's a shame, that's what it is.
- [Bill] Yes, yes it is.
- [Jeff] You can argue all you want,
but the flag, well, it's been thrown.
- [Bill] That's right.
If it's three pumps, the refs
not gonna take it away now.
- [Jeff] No he's not.
Duration and intensity
doesn't make any difference.
- [Bill] Well, Jeff, let's
have a look at the replay here
to see if indeed he
did do the three pumps.
- [Jeff] All right, no question.
There is the first one.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Agreed, right.
- [Jeff] And then coming
up is the second one.
- [Bill] Okay? Yes, very clear.
It's the third.
- [Jeff] We'll see it,
it's coming up right here.
- [Bill] Just not sure.
Oh yeah, you're right.
There's absolutely three pumps there.
Oh, apologies to all those
watching with young children.
Clearly unintentional.
- He's disgusting.
Bernard, he's disgusting.
He's not even flight crew.
He's an airplane technician.
I mean, come on.
That's- and he talks too much.
That's why I like you.
You don't talk, you just
listen, that's good.
(dinging)
Okay.
And the captain has turned on
the fastened seatbelt sign.
Got a little turbulence coming up.
Should be no problem.
Just remain in your seat
until the sign is turned off.
Thank you for your cooperation.
Okay.
- Excuse me, I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
- Hi, excuse me.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
I gonna need you to take your seat.
The fastened seatbelt sign is on.
- Yeah, I'm just gonna go to
the bathroom for a second.
I'll be right back, okay?
- Yeah, I understand what you wanna do.
Unfortunately, I'm gonna
need you to observe
the fasten seatbelt sign.
That'd be much appreciated.
- Right, I just, I read on the internet
that it's not against the law
for me to go to the bathroom
while the fasten seatbelt sign is on, so.
- Seatbelt sign is on.
- But is it against the law, though?
- The light is on.
(sucking teeth)
- Is it against the law?
- You see that there's a picture
of a seatbelt on that sign.
- I know, but is it
against the law, though?
- The fasten seat belt sign is on.
- But is it against the law, though?
- [Mark] Sir, the seat belt sign is on.
- But is it against the law?
- Seat belt sign is on.
- Seat belt sign.
- But is it against the law?
- It's on.
- Law.
- Seatbelt sign is on.
- Legal.
- Lawful.
- Seatbelt sign is on.
Sir, you're being difficult.
- Law.
- You're being very difficult.
- Law. Law.
Law. Law.
- Seatbelt. Seatbelt.
- Not illegal. Not illegal.
- Not illegal.
- Okay.
- Legal.
- Fasten your seatbelt.
- [Mark] Sir!
I have to **** and I have to (beep).
- Sir, can you lower your voice?
- In the toilet.
- Can you lower your voice?
- [Passenger] I have to
**** and I have to (beep).
- Okay, lower your intensity.
- You're louder than me.
- You're yelling in my face.
- Sir, you're the one who I think needs
to tone it down right now.
You are screaming at me.
- You're hurting my ear drums.
(tongues smacking)
That wasn't a word.
You're not saying a word there.
- This is a word.
- That's not.
- That's not a word.
- [Mark] That's not a word,
that's a tongue trick.
Okay, sir, sir, sir, if you would like-
- I would not like to.
I would not like to sit down.
What I'd like to do is go
take a (beep) in the bathroom
because it's not against the law.
So, I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Okay?
Mark with a K.
(intense music)
(deep breathing)
(intense music continues)
(seatbelt clacking)
(gasping)
(whooshing)
(plane shuddering)
(passengers screaming)
(intense music)
(crashing)
(screaming)
(suspenseful music)
(chant music)
(screaming)
(engine whirring)
(whooshing)
(screaming)
(thudding)
(beeping)
(screaming)
(beeping continues)
(chant music)
(thudding)
(smacking)
(intense chant music)
(thudding)
- Hoo!
(dinging)
- And your captain has turned off
the fastened seatbelt sign.
Feel free to move around the cabin.
Thank you for your cooperation.
(intense music)
(whooshing)
(bell ringing)
(class chattering)
- Nice to see ya.
Good to see ya, okay.
All right, everybody
just let's settle down,
settle in, and like just totally,
let's get our math on, okay?
All right, guys.
So, um...
(class laughing)
Ya! Oh!
(all laughing)
All right Jimmy.
(Jimmy makes strange noises)
- Somebody's got a little extra energy
from Phys. Ed., right?
- Woo. Woo.
Ne, ne, ah!
- Jimmy, buddy.
Hey buddy, let's, okay,
let's knock it off.
Okay?
(class laughing)
Okay.
(Jimmy mocks the teacher)
You got me.
He got me, right, guys?
Jimmy, dude, all right,
let's take our seat.
(all laughing)
That's great, that's great, that's great.
- Boop beep.
- Very good.
Bravo, Jimmy, I'm just gonna-
You guys can clap.
(class cheering)
- Oh!
- That was awesome.
Oh, and I thank you.
I thank you for the entertainment, man.
(Jimmy makes strange noises)
Jimmy, let's go man.
Hey buddy, I don't wanna
harsh your vibe, man, but-
- Ah! Eureka!
(class continues laughing)
- I'm gonna be honest with you,
really pushing my buttons now, Jimmy.
(Jimmy beeping and booping)
(class laughing)
- You're driving crazy, man.
- Zoom.
(Jimmy mimicking a car shaking)
- That's enough.
You want me to write
your name on the board?
(slapping)
(class laughing)
- [Jimmy] Ah!
Hold on, hold on.
- Okay, Jimmy, do you want
me to call principal Martel?
(Jimmy gasping mockingly)
That would not be ********, would it?
(Jimmy chattering)
(class laughing)
Okay, you know what, Jimmy, you know what?
Why don't you come up
and teach the class, man?
Hmm?
Wouldn't that be awesome?
- Moi?
(class laughing)
- Yeah, come on up, do it.
(slapping)
- No and then you know
what I'm gonna do, Jimmy?
I'll just sit here.
How about that, Jimmy?
And then we can all watch
how you're being disruptive.
(mocking)
(class laughing)
Oh, I see, that's supposed to be me.
Right.
All right Jimmy, okay.
I see that.
I get it's supposed to be me.
It's time to be done, Jimmy.
- Don't you dare, Jim, what is-
(class laughing)
- Oh yeah?
Oh yeah?
(trilling tongue)
Well, this is you, Jimmy.
(screaming and whooping)
I'm you Jimmy.
(screaming)
How about that, Jimmy, huh?
Oh, I'm gonna slap five.
Gimme five.
(slapping)
Huh, how about that, huh?
That's you, Jimmy.
I'm Jimmy.
And I need attention.
Yeah, I'm Jimmy.
I'm Jimmy.
Oh, look here.
That's the funniest thing ever
happened in the whole world.
I'm Jimmy, I want attention.
Wiki, wiki, wiki, wiki, wiki.
I'm Jimmy, I'm Jimmy.
Wee, me, me, me, me.
- Mr. Flyer!
- Principal Martel!
No, what?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
It was Jimmy.
It was Jimmy, Principal Martel.
No, Jimmy.
- Why?
- It was Jimmy.
It was Jimmy.
(class cheering)
(all shouting Jimmy)
(triumphant music)
(cheering)
(funky music)
♪ Oh, I want you, ♪
♪ But I don't need ya. ♪